what is the meaning of life
i know it's it's a big question to ask
and this kind of existential
philosophical questioning is mainly
considered as little more than an
antiquated pastime a hobby shared
exclusively by old men with a bit too
much time on their hands
which to be fair is actually a pretty
good way to describe much of the manga
vagabond central cast
what i love about manga is how many of
them actually go into this question
beneath the surface of the pages
raising interpretations and hidden
depths of meaning that give color to the
black and white panels
but i do emphasize that it's beneath the
surface it doesn't suffocate you
distracts from the action and story to
make it feel like some fluffy and lofty
microcosm for a combined purpose as
humans
but it's always there a small but key
part of the larger story
and as someone who is partial to
overanalyzing anime and manga to put it
lightly
these kinds of stories are always my
absolute favorite
mushishi and its innumerable morals
about the small things in life
parasite and its questioning of
humanity's values
iniashiki and its exploration of how
emotions define people
and in particular vagabonds and how it
questions one's purpose in life as we
follow a reckless wanderer and swordsman
turn into an introspective philosopher
vagabond is a manga based on aji
yoshikawa's epic novel musashi a
fictional account of the life of
miyamoto musashi arguably the most
famous japanese swordsman to have ever
lived
but more so than being just a swordsman
perhaps being what western cultures
would dub as a renaissance man miyamoto
was also revered in his later life for
his ink painting calligraphy philosophy
and writing
but of course he was not always this
vagabond follows miyamoto's story
starting at 17 years old as he becomes a
ronin a warrior with no lord nor master
and a vagabond a wanderer with no job
nor home
miyamoto's goal is initially simple it's
to become the strongest
perhaps too simple actually for such a
complex revered and acclaimed manga at
first glance
but as miyamoto continues on his travels
and finds that he's just a small part of
this larger world along the way through
his encounters with samurai and
swordsmen of unparalleled strength
we learn that mastering the art of
swordsmanship and becoming strong
can only be done after abandoning those
shallow ideas of power and exploring the
greatest depths of philosophy and
introspection
that true strength is far more than just
physical
and so what is that philosophy vagabond
talks about returning to my very first
question in this video how can
questioning the meaning of life
translate itself into the fluid
movements of a blade
if anything intuition would tell us that
bogging oneself down with such deep and
overbearing thoughts would distract from
the simplicity that is swordsmanship
after all musashi has no master
throughout the story he hones his craft
through battle by living constantly a
mere sword's length away from the cold
embrace of death itself
a moment's distraction or second guess
could be your demise in this manga for
many characters it actually is
and perhaps that contrast between the
overarching theme and the reality of
battle and its intensity is exactly why
vagabond is so revered as a story
the mangaka inoue takahiko challenges
himself by detailing exactly how a young
fresh-faced and ambitious soul seeking
to become stronger grew into miyamoto
musashi a figure whose philosophy in
both battle and life especially
would end up echoing across the rest of
time to come
i hope that my discussion and
exploration into this can further both
your understanding and appreciation for
this masterpiece of a manga
even if just a little bit
let's
dig a little deeper
[Music]
vagabond is a largely fictional
retelling of miyamoto musashi's story
it's important to understand the
truthful aspects that it all of course
came from
most of musashi's legacy has been
preserved in two of the books he
authored in the final years of his life
the book of five rings and the path of
aloneness
now the book of five rings mainly deals
with actual swordsmanship the nitin
ichidu style that he became famous for a
unique double-bladed swordsmanship that
allowed him to go undefeated his whole
life in duels
and going through this book is
tiring
it's split into five books actually that
of earth water fire wind and the void
the book of earth spent its time
discussing swordsmanship and leadership
in terms of building a house a process
almost as interesting as watching paint
dry the book of fire talks about timing
in battle water talks about basic
techniques wind seems to just be
musashi's rose session of a number of
different sword styles that aren't his
own and the void talks about his mindset
for life and everything
i think now i get why i read manga over
this stuff
i found the path of aloneness far more
interesting than the book of five rings
because as implied in its title i felt a
very strong connection between the
presets listed in this book and the path
musashi takes in the story of vagabond
itself
be detached from desire
never be saddened by separation
be indifferent to where you live
there's plenty that you can see in
musashi's character based on this
historical evidence
in the story he's always different from
other people be it because of his
deep-rooted animalistic rage that scares
the common folk or his unpredictability
in battle against rigid swordsmen
but on this long list from the path of
aloneness there was one specific preset
that i felt resonated very strongly with
the larger idea that vagabond tries to
invoke through musashi's story
think lightly of yourself
and deeply of the world
musashi finds himself humbled constantly
throughout vagabond he gets his ass
handed to him a couple times and
sometimes he loses before the fight even
starts
and what is very interesting is that
though musashi always comes back to the
opponent he loses to and
well wins he never really
trains
or at least in the technical sense of
the word
the time that other mangas spend
watching a character learn specific new
techniques or get weapon upgrades
vagabond instead invests in miyamoto
wandering through nature simply in his
own thoughts
it's interesting that the time spent
between arcs and vagabond what most
manga use as forgettable sections of
simple filler or build up to the next
big arc
vagabond instead uses to deeply enrich
musashi's character as he travels alone
onto the next step of his journey
but now why do the readers just accept
that musashi continues to get naturally
stronger and is able to beat enemies on
the next try without any concrete
evidence of him getting stronger
why does it work
in vagabond
vagabond doesn't spend all this time
watching musashi do strength training or
learn new techniques because when
looking at the story overall
the physical is not what manifested
miyamoto musashi the renowned
philosopher and swordsman
it's his principle and beliefs about
life that still remain to this day
this isn't to say that we never see
musashi adapt in battle or get stronger
of course
but the story is very purposefully left
open-ended in almost every way
after returning to battle in shoon aside
from sitting under a waterfall for a
while little is known about how
musashi's time spent in the wild allowed
him to grow as a fighter and a person if
you were to describe how musashi was
different when rematching the yoshioka
clan one year apart in manga time
aside from fighting a couple strong guys
along the way most of whom weren't
actually even swordsmen there's not much
to note physically aside from a couple
extra scars on his face and a bit more
hair on his head but it is obvious to
tell that he's a completely changed man
between these events from the beginning
compared to the end of the story and
it's because of how he thinks and how he
acts
because the moments when we witness him
traversing the world offer insight into
exactly how his view on swordsmanship
and life
constantly changes instead of just
giving him shallow upgrades each time he
has to fight a new enemy
coming back to that quote earlier think
lightly of yourself and deeply of the
world it's actually used by takahiko but
phrased in a much more poetic way i
think and one that is befitting when
describing musashi's travels across
japan
preoccupied with a single leaf you won't
see the tree
preoccupied with a single tree
you'll miss the entire forest
in vagabond there's no point to a new
battle strategy or blade if it can be
stopped by a mere backscratcher
something we do see happen in the story
there's no point for overflowing passion
or animosity in battle if you can't get
past a cool and collected man's sword
as musashi grows older and wiser through
this story the only enemies he finds
that he cannot win against are those who
he cannot actually fight
old former swordsmen who make him
realize that when everything is long
gone and time has passed as your body
deteriorates
all you have left at the end of the road
is your mind
musashi comes to realize he's nothing
compared to these men wise beyond his
comprehension
nothing compared to the forces of nature
itself
nothing the moment a blade ends up
inevitably slicing his neck and he's
nothing more than food for the vultures
at some point in the story of vagabond
before you even realize
musashi no longer shows signs of rage in
battle
you find that he's actually not even the
one starting the fights anymore he
doesn't blindly attack his enemies to
keep slicing his way to the top
he becomes
kinder
he isn't necessarily in the pursuit of
being kinder per se but it all comes
back to the idea of the path of
aloneness
what musashi learns from these men is
that he is simply one small part of all
that exists and the path of aloneness
life itself means disregarding
unnecessary technique rage beliefs
but also understanding that once you
leave all that behind amidst everything
that exists
nature people swords death you are
nothing
finding the strength within yourself to
admit this is what musashi realizes and
what allows him to let go of his
preconceived ideas of battle and the
ferocity needed to continue in life
what formed miyamoto musashi what formed
his heart
after all
all truly strong people
are kind
it's been a while since i made a video
and if you've made it this far thank you
for watching i've got a lot planned for
2022 and i'm excited to really get back
into it and
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses